i knew it this was an intervention
we got the lights and we got the camera
it's an intervention
for anyone looking to break into the
movie business and make a living at the
same time
what's the best path for them
um i would say
but
well what do what do they want to do in
the movie business that's a better
question because like you know you could
make a living doing
what you want to do but i mean if you're
saying like just like
person a just wants to work in the film
business and needs to pay rent and like
there is no like aspiration of what they
want to do
okay well suppose they eventually would
like to be a director but they they
realize they can't just start out that
way so they're not starting out from an
extra point of view where they could
just go to central casting and actually
get a paycheck
i mean today's work you know
crew work i mean that's how you can like
work up the ranks
or like you know if they have access to
financing or distributors they could you
know be a producer put together a
project and then they can kind of
negotiate their pay from the budget
there but like the guaranteed you know
money
right off the bat is is starting up in
crew and and working your way up the
first few movies i did as a director um
i didn't get paid i i did for free it
was you know like the first three movies
i did uh you know i just used the
budgets to put it on screen
and i thought like a director made money
off of how the movie did um not that and
then i remember i got uh hired to direct
a movie and was my first time getting
paid to direct a movie i got paid a
thousand dollars to direct this movie
and i was like holy [ __ ] i could get
paid to do this
um
so i mean like it's it's uh you know
it's
it's
it's definitely um
the i mean the best way to fully be paid
right off the bat would be would be crew
work
what if someone says well i'm
want to be paid
well i want to be paid um my services
are valuable i realize i'm brand new
but i want you to pay me for what to
work yeah but as what okay um i'm gonna
be
a gaffer
yeah if it's crew work okay yeah i want
you to pay me yeah you you they would
pay the person they wouldn't work for
free
i mean
unless it's your friends nobody's
working for free i mean you gotta you
gotta hit minimum wage you know okay
at least here in california um i mean if
it's your friends and you're making a
movie over the weekend together and
everybody's doing favors that's when
people are working for free like you
know my first few movies i was a crew of
three people it was me my my buddy and
my other friend uh and then the second
movie i did it was just me
you know like so and then the third
movie i did it was like you know i think
my friend and my other friend that like
like high school friends you know like
people i'd like known a long time so
like they didn't you know none of us got
paid we were just doing it for fun um
and and to make something cool
um but yeah like you know when you're
getting in the professional business
where money is being spent you can't
have people working for free
uh you know
unless it's like a college internship
program
i mean you were willing to put in your
time even though some of these were your
own projects yeah well see i was i was
willing to do that um you know and and
some people may be willing to do that
and maybe that's possible but
you know um
the that was like before if that makes
sense like that was like earlier like
like labor laws have changed in
california
so if you're putting together a project
with some friends and it's just like
nobody's getting paid and you're doing
it as like an art project for fun
maybe that's one thing but if it's like
a movie that has like a budget and
people are being paid to do this movie
um you can't really have
anybody working for free on it anymore
like that's that's kind of
changed that's like um the labor laws
have changed
but you would be willing to do it for
free again if you were just starting out
not not now i realized if i if i
rewinded and could make the same choices
that i made i would do the same thing
yeah
right because it what do you think about
people that say well no i have to have
some
financial incentive behind me i won't
make these films unless i i get paid
even if it's your name on it you're the
director you're the screenwriter you can
so you wrote it you you wrote it and
you're directing it and you won't make
it unless you're getting paid
um i mean i to each their own you know
what i mean i i would say like if i was
starting out and somebody gave me the
opportunity to make my first movie again
and it was just you know just the money
to make the movie and i couldn't take a
paycheck
i would
make the movie like that's what i did
and i would do it again um
but you know if somebody maybe has you
know two kids and they can't take the
time off because like you know i
everybody's
circumstances are different i'm just
trying to get in that headspace you know
it depends if you can't afford it like
if you're living paycheck to paycheck
and you can't afford to take that time
off to do that movie to do this you know
i understand you know um everybody's
circumstances are unique and different
have you tried to structure your life so
that you have more freedom to to be able
to take the projects you want to take
without having to be dictated by
a paycheck
somewhat yeah for sure i've been
definitely trying to get pickier and
stuff but i also remember my dad always
told me that every movie that i did
from now until i was 30 would always be
remembered as my early movies
and so i've kind of kept that in my mind
is like everything that i do is like
this is like me learning this is my
early years and then like you know when
i once i hit 30 that's when i'm like you
know okay then that's when i'm making
movies you know so like right now i
don't know if i've actually started yet
um but you know i'll definitely be
pickier the the more and more you know i
make stuff and i'm i'm trying to be
you know
pickier now but
as as you know a filmmaker in general
like you know i just like making movies
i like telling stories i like being on
set and you know
it's
it's something i enjoy um so it's it's
hard to
not want to do the thing that you have
fun doing you know
would you say you're almost addicted to
being on a movie set i mean are you
almost your best self when you're on a
movie set i knew it this was an
intervention
we got the lights and we got the camera
it's an intervention oh [ __ ] yeah doctor
so-and-so
come out here bring out dr phil
oh god
it says welcome too now i see the
welcome again ah
no um yeah no i don't love you
we all we all love you
[Laughter]
no of course i'm addicted to being on
set um i i'm addicted to making movies i
you know i really enjoy it um and i
think the thing i enjoy the most is like
i actually feel myself getting better
each time
and so like i really enjoy like it's
like going to the gym like you go to the
gym and you're like you know like
obviously i don't go to the gym that
much but you know you're like lifting
weights and like you know you could feel
yourself like the next time you could
lift a little bit heavier weight you're
like oh this is cool like i can see like
myself
getting better at what i do like i can
feel it so it's like you know i i enjoy
that
we love you james we love you james we
love you we just need you we just need
you to stop
stop making movies james take some time
off
spend it with martin your cat
well when do you know that you need to
take time off or you don't because it
seems like with this business it's feast
or famine so you would probably have a
tough time turning down work i mean [ __ ]
when do i
um
i don't know i don't know how to answer
that
um
i guess take time off when you need to
take time off
you know the most important thing is
mental health so you know do what's
right for you
uh mentally um you know i know i had
recently i had a movie that i was gonna
do and and i told them i didn't want to
do it um because
it was gonna be my only time off um in
like this year
uh
and so i ended up not doing the movie
because i wanted to be able to have
some time off you know i was like i
don't want to work through the holidays
and this now like i want to have some
time
off is that hard for you to turn down
work
oh yeah totally it's totally hard it's
totally hard
because you know then you start going
well it could have been really cool and
blah blah blah but like you know it's
one of those things with like
i don't know
it's
it's definitely hard i mean you know
because then i'm like well what am i
doing i'm sitting at home playing video
games
like
like
after like three days of doing that
you're like all right let's get back to
work
sitting at home playing video games
eating subway sandwiches let's get back
to this